6
24 your friday morning so neighbors are
helping neighbors where the 95 meets the
northern 215 beltway come on let's go
centennial bowling so today we have more
from a centennial hills facebook group
speaking up on the project debbie posted
hey you know what driving east on the
215 from durango
once you get to where that old signal
was for osa blanca the roadway itself in
that specific area is very bumpy and
chewed up other drivers are slamming on
their brakes causing issues behind them
do they plan on patching that lane up
before the project is close to
completion thank you well fellow
facebook poster christopher
stepped right up with an answer and he
says that whole area is to be replaced
as the project progresses
then completely different talking about
how long that whole project seems to be
going by the heaping helping of snark
from a facebook poster named brent he
writes the three guys working on it for
the past 10
years and the next 10 years are doing
the best they can
basically a year for raiders stadium and
20 years for this priorities huh but you
know what ndot really has been pretty
straight up with completion timelines
not just to us in the media but also
on their website that's tracked all the
work in the area from the beginning
we've got that link
on our website eightnewsnow.com buckle
up drive carefully please put on the
phone if there's something driving you
crazy
news
email
me
traffic8newsnow.com